Hi, I’m Evan Carmichael.
Welcome to another edition of Ask Evan.
Today’s question comes from one of my
forum readers Anthony
who wrote in asking about business plan
and he said, “Is a good business plan
the first thing that you need to do to start a business.”
As much of a fan of business plans that I am Anthony
and thank you for the question
I think a lot of people go through that question as well
I don’t think it’s the first thing that you should do
and the reason being, when you’re creating your business plan
you should really have a good sense of your market
and what you’re going to do to create your product
and service and sell it.
In the early stages of a business
what you really need to do
is start talking to customers to figure out
what kind of business you should launch
and the best type of business you can launch
is building around your customers.
So you go start talking to potential customers.
Find out what their problems are their pain points
and try to develop a solution that can help them.
We made this mistake, one of my earlier companies
we spent an entire summer drafting a business plan
that we thought was awesome
and of course our customers
are going to want this product
and this is, you know, the best thing ever
and we spent so much time researching
and figured we had the best thing
but then when we, you know
got to actually launching it turns out that the customer
we’re going after didn’t really care
or give us the time of day.
Now luckily we had, you know, enough still in our product
to make it successful and we would find other customers
but we spent all this time creating this business plan
that we thought was amazing
and then when we went out to actually test it in the market
we found out that it didn’t hold any water.
So the best thing that you can do in the beginning
when you’re first starting your business
or you’re thinking about starting a business
is go start talking to customers
and they’ll tell you what they need
what they like, how you can help them
and from there you’ll get the information you need
to be able to create your business plan.
The danger doing it to the other way
is your business plan will be, you know
useless and extinct, you know
the day you actually start going out and marketing your product.
As you launch your business
your business plan is going to change.
You’re going to get new opportunities
customers will come to you with new problems
your marketing strategy will change
your expenses might change a little bit.
So your business plan will constantly have to change a little bit
but it’s best if you can to have a good concept
from the beginning built around what you know will sell
and what customers want.
So my number one thing if you’re starting a business
is just go start talking to customers.
Find out their problems
build a solution around their needs
and then once you’ve got a sense of what their challenges are
and you’re able to get a couple of orders
ideally coming in you can create your business plan
on how you’re going to create this, you know
company out of this idea
and be able to go out and expand to other companies
build a team, build your facilities if you need to
and continue to grow the business.
So hopefully that helps Anthony.
For those of you watching, if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs-up.
I always love seeing those come in.
And if you have a thought for Anthony
or you have a question I’d love to hear it
if you want to leave a comment underneath the video.
So thank you and we’ll see you on the next episode.